welcome to this video playing [ __ ] game
again and he's playing be three Wow all
the time really I guess all the time if
I really find it boring to have be three
years later gets me all the time um can
I do something crazy come on I'm doing
something crazy just just for fun it's
probably not very good yeah but how do i
am justify that maybe i can i can get
the night on the light squares will be
nice yes t5 you will play a three
okay let's just see what happens here 85
crazy stuff I wanted to go to g5
actually after move like d3 but this is
really ridiculous yeah this was this was
clear but also also possible
but not something that I had pretty much
thought through right you can go to h5
this is the problem wanted to go nigh g5
/ taking you to h5
intending rook age six yeah yeah if you
play with fire you shouldn't complain
about getting burned so it's um it's all
my own on my own fault yeah maybe from a
know maybe there is there is something
about it black pay looks terribly shaky
I don't release I don't see a reputation
at the moment but it would be very
normal if there is one yeah not not much
choice maybe this isn't that bad i mean
if Queen sure that that night on h4 is
not great really isn't I can give the
trick
he's not threatening anything really
right I am we're really i want to get
castle Bishop to b6 maybe Bishop f6 IMF
covered that's not so bad if i can get
long castle in and then that's really a
really a position not that bad hmm
coming to f3 okay i'm canceling takes
and f5 is probably not bad i'm checking
it's also it's also also on I have many
pieces on his King yeah that's that's
not bad let's push stuff him yeah I have
a huge score against him 16 wins four
losses no draw it seems no draw and this
does not look very dry again may I could
have taken already I am Not sure Knight
to h3 years also possibility Teague's
okay why not
Knight takes I will take g3 here I can
ok I need to get this get this out of
the way I was thinking Bishop g3 might
be a moose hook China no not possible
this is threatening push-up g35 I have
am stood i still can play it I think it
takes I cannot hmm ok Jake spawn eggs he
does hit the save me to save himself and
I want the night night only four would
be great the only issue is it takes lots
of time yeah maybe maybe I can get this
in right f7 g5 to be formed if I that
I'm in excellent shape and it's not like
he has great news Wow
a 3 is a bit like I don't know yeah
planning a picnic White House is still
already burning or something that's
never really going to be good a three
yeah my plan is working what get you
allow me this with the tempo even time
more hey bishop chicks may I come on
there must be when I cannot calculate
this but this must be a win takes Knight
takes rook takes rook edge form may I
can just take right or queen takes I
mean at all it all looks rather good
white resign yeah I don't know I I
simply have to this guy's number even
with the crazy stuff um the allergy five
assists is really not a serious move but
turn out to to work out quite well at
the end computer is not really thinking
it is so bad actually funny but ok it's
it's very very risky at least ok yeah I
know somewhere around here it feels like
I should they should be punished but
this seems to hold for some reason yeah
this was probably a bad idea I am you
should probably do this to to have this
oops not that night to h5 I mean yeah
that looks very dangerous probably this
is the way to go stock regime is giving
why the huge edge yeah that's that's the
point here I'm really not sure Oh Bishop
g7 was winning just wrapping my rook
funny no I didn't see that one ok I went
here again Bishop g7 we both didn't see
it again Bishop g7 and by now I'm having
a good position yeah everything is in
the attack that probably could have done
something better route g3 winsome
now yeah that's that's nice young like
wins okay I didn't see that but I like
this idea the only thing that's really
weird is that he totally ignored it yeah
he gave me so many Tempe and here it all
wins it really nigeria's even made ok
this is this is totally enough Wow yeah
the weird stuff even-even one here I've
got 17 for against the guy ok thanks for
watching